Crouch's senior curator of aeronautics
at the National Air and Space Museum a
dream of wings is his book on the
evolution of aviation and the
centuries-old quest for flight during
this hour long talk you'll see slides of
early designs such as the Chinese kites
of a thousand BC and the wind tunnels
and gliders of the late 1800s good
morning I'm Kathy Allen the director of
the college park Aviation Museum I'd
like to welcome you to the final session
of the 15th annual mutual concerns of
Air and Space Museum seminar this
meeting of museum professionals from
across the country and around the world
is a collaboration between the National
Air and Space Museum and the American
Association of museums for information
about the 2003 seminar please visit the
American Association of museums website
at WWF in u.s. org now I'd like to
welcome you to a dream of wings
presented by Tom crouch Tom Crouch is
the senior curator for aeronautics at
the National Air and Space Museum where
he's had a diverse and distinguished
career since nineteen seventy-four in
1989 Tom became the chair of the
Department of aeronautics becoming the
museum senior curator of aeronautics in
1998 in 2001 president clinton appointed
Crouch chairman of the advisory council
for the National centennial of flight
Commission an honor to be sure tom is
most known to us for his love of early
aviation and particularly for his
knowledge and expertise on the Wright
brothers and their achievements as you
can imagine Thomas had a very busy year
these last few years as the planning and
enthusiasm for the hundredth anniversary
of the right centennial at Kitty Hawk
goes into full swing Tom's many books
particularly those on early
aviation are wonderful resources for
those of us who are interested in
aviation history his book on the Wright
brothers the bishops voice is considered
by many to be the authoritative history
of the rights and how they were able to
accomplish such a magnificent feat in
history Tom's ability to make time for
those of us who are also trying to tell
the tale of early aviation weather we're
big or small has learned too many
admirers all over the world this year
tom was selected to receive the
Smithsonian's distinguished scholar
lecturer award and you're about to find
out why I'd like to present Tom crouch
thanks Kathy and thanks to all of you
and to the Planning Committee for this
year's mutual concerns seminar for
inviting me to to do this you'll notice
that the topic given in your program
will be a little different than what i'm
going to talk about at least i hope you
notice that notice the difference WW
Norton my publisher just brought out a
new addition of an older book of mine
called a dream of wings this one's
revised and updated and so what I
thought I would do what I thought would
be really appropriate as we approach the
one year mark before the 100th
anniversary of flight would be to talk a
little bit about a subject that I
haven't talked about in a long time and
that is the existence of a group of
flight enthusiasts who set the stage for
the invention of the airplane over 100
years ago basically the the subject that
a dream of wings was written about so
let's go ahead we have a lot of slides
here these two gentlemen I hope you'll
recognize Wilbur and Orville Wright
Wilbur of course is the one on your left
and Orville's the one on your right when
you look at them I think you can tell a
lot about them a lot about what kind of
human beings they really were for
example Orville was the natty dresser of
the pair and I think you can see some of
that in this this picture he's in the
light suit with the snazzy socks and
just looking like a really dashing
fellow as in fact he was if you want to
understand how their story starts most
of the time people take you all the way
back to sort of the dawn of human
consciousness and the the role that
flight plays in our mythology our
literature our religion again going all
the way back to the very
beginning of a human prehistory really
but the awful truth is that the real
origins of the airplane of aviation did
very little real recognition people pay
a lot of attention for example to
Leonardo da Vinci of da Vinci of course
was one of the great minds of the
Renaissance and certainly one of the
great artists of the Renaissance no
doubt about any of that and he was
interested in flight but the awful truth
is that Louie Leonardo's work in
aviation was almost completely unknown
until the middle late years of the 19th
century that was so because Leonardo
wrote his notebooks his codices in code
sort of a kind of backwards writing in
the first place so you couldn't just
pick them up and read what he'd been
thinking the other thing was that after
leonardo's death his notebooks were
widely dispersed all over Europe you
couldn't go to one place to find
leonardo's papers and again the result
is that while people knew Leonardo's art
and they knew he'd been interested in
technology even in flight technology the
details of his interest were almost
entirely unknown until really just
before the invention of the airplane so
if you really want to find the roots of
the airplane you don't go to mythology
or even great figures like Leonardo you
really have to start with anonymous
medieval craftsmen technicians sort of
proto engineers the image that you see
on the screen now is the oldest
illustration of a powered flying machine
from the European tradition its 14th
century and you see the fellow who has a
string in his hand the artist who did
this didn't quite understand what was
going on the guy's hand should be up
holding that bulbous thing and of course
when he pulls the string that string
inside the spindle is wrapped around the
so when he pulls it that helicopter is
going to go out of the top of the shaft
and bump up against the ceiling that toy
which first appears in Europe here in
the 14th century is going to remain in
Europe for the next 500 years and have
really enormous influence on on the
keeping the dream of flight alive 400
years after this illustration was done
Sir George Cayley who were going to look
at in a minute began his aeronautical
career fooling around with these little
helicopter toys and a century after Sir
George Cayley Wilbur and Orville Wright
began their career fooling around with
these little helicopter toys so
generation after generation and the
European tradition these little toys are
real important toys the whole notion of
play doesn't really get enough
recognition as impetus for technology
but you can really see it here this
child's toy that had an enormous impact
really on the European aeronautics so
did these gizmos it's a little hard to
see in this illumination manuscript
illumination but you're looking at early
windmills in the European tradition
beginning during the High Middle Ages
the windmill and the waterwheel to
become really important in powering a
sort of mini industrial revolution
during the High Middle Ages and it
became really important for the
anonymous craftsmen who built windmills
and water wheels to understand what was
happening why these things work the way
they did and in fact how you could build
better ones then then existed and that
tradition of using the power of the air
and the power of water fluid dynamics to
do work to generate power that's going
to operate machines and factories and
that sort of thing is another really
important route of the flying machine in
fact and kites two are extraordinarily
important
this is an early illustration of a
particular kind of European kites kites
as you know probably date in the Far
East in China to a thousand BC and they
arrived in Europe about well 1200 1300
in in that general ballpark and become
just extraordinarily important in the
history of flying machines because as
we'll see at the turn of the century
when people are getting serious about
inventing the airplane they really only
have one flying device that they can use
to test air foils and aerodynamic
notions and so on and that's the kite
that's where basically virtually all of
the important fine machine experimenters
begin so in other words you see the
roots of Aeronautics coming out of these
simple devices that are either invented
or appear in Europe during the High
Middle Ages now the awful truth is that
if you really want to understand the
roots of the flying machine you can
begin with this guy Sir George Cayley
who was an English baronet he had a a an
estate brompton hall in kent in england
you can really begin with Sir George
Cayley and not very much that happens
before him in the Year 1800 has any real
effect on the invention of the airplane
there are a few things that happen but
as I said it's it's not Leonardo it's
not what you would expect 18th century
studies for example of the way in which
windmills and water wheels work the work
of pioneer engineers really
first-generation engineers people like
the englishman john smeaton for example
who's publishing on the efficiency of
windmills and water wheels in the mid
18th century that material was important
and some contributions from some basic
contributions from physicists as well
from Galileo to Newton we're going to
have an impact on flying machine studies
either positive or negative
because some misunderstandings came out
of the reading of those early physical
texts but with those few exceptions
basically the story the invention of the
airplane begins was Sir George Cayley
and that's because Kaylee is the first
guy who really reaches back into the
18th century and the Scientific
Revolution and pulls out those few
scientific threads that are going to be
of value in designing airplanes and puts
them to use in designing airplanes john
smeaton for example who had done those
windmill and waterwheel studies had not
the slightest interest in flight Cayley
had the understanding to recognize how
important his work was for the design of
flying machines and he applied it for
the first time to the design of
airplanes and the same things true with
the physicists of the Scientific
Revolution kaylee recognized what was
important and he created the first
simple algebraic equations that you
could use to calculate the amount of
lift that a particular wing area was
going to generate at a particular angle
of attack and went forward from there
one of the other reasons he's important
is because what you see on the screen
kaylee not only picked a few juicy plums
out of the past that would be useful in
the design of flying machines he
basically invented aeronautical
engineering research he took a handful
of engineering instruments that had been
developed in the 18th century for the
most part for the most part invented by
people like ballast itions who wanted to
study the motion of objects through the
air cannon balls or things of that sort
and also people like john smeaton who
had studied water wheels and windmills
and kaylee came up with instruments like
this it's a whirling arm and until the
invention of the wind tunnel in the
1870s the whirling arm is going to be
the single most important engineering in
interment that's available to somebody
who's interested in flying machine
research you can see you over here on
your right then at the very right-hand
edge of the the painting or the drawing
this is kayleigh's drawing by the way
there's a wait and of course as you can
see when you release the weight the line
is tight around that spindle wound
around that spindle so when you release
the weight over on the far left that arm
with surfaces mounted on either side of
the arm is going to whirl through the
air and kaylee had a way of gathering
data that way this is only one of the
kinds of instruments that he used but
again the critical thing is that he's
the first one to begin applying real
engineering principles to the design of
flying machines we hear an awful lot of
talk about science and the invention of
the airplane another one of those awful
truth is that science in terms of an
attempt to understand how the world
works why a wing generates lift for
example had very little to do with all
of this the invention of the airplane
was really the work of engineers who
were gathering data how much lift and
drag does this surface generate and how
can I apply that to the design of a
mechanical flying machine those are the
kinds of approaches that were fruitful
when it came to moving toward the
invention of the airplane so Kayleigh
not only establishes sort of a
foundation for everyone else but he's
also the first guy who puts what he's
learned and what others have learned to
work in the design of airplanes and what
you see on the screen is really what
amounts to the world's first real
airplane kaylee based this on his own
research and the research that he'd
picked up from smeaton and others and
the front of course is to your left and
the tail of course is to your right you
see the wing in the middle it's actually
just a fabric surface it's
between two poles so you're not looking
at anything that's very sophisticated
here but what you're looking at of
course is significant because for the
first time somebody's come up with a
flying machine that has separate systems
for lift and control the wing doesn't
beat it's only designed to generate lift
and the tail is only designed to control
the machine in the air and it has a
separate propulsion system too and of
course since this is a model glider
gravity's a propulsion system for this
one this is also in all probability the
first machine that carried a hue heavier
than air machine winged machine that
really carried a human being into the
air in a significant sort of way over
the period of his career which began in
about 1799 and runs until the time of
his death in the early 1850s kaylee
probably through flew three people not
himself but three volunteers we hope I
think all of you probably know the story
about the most famous of those flights
when he got his coachman to make a
flight and a thing that looked like this
this is kayleigh's drawing up of what's
called the Coachman's machine because
the guy was his coachman and he's
supposed to have made a short sailing
flight over a little veil at Brompton
hall and after a hard landing he's
supposed to have gone up to kaylee and
said sir george i was hired to drive and
not to fly whether the story is true or
not we have every reason to believe that
the flight itself is true there are good
eyewitness descriptions of it and and
that sort of thing so for a whole
variety of reasons kaylee is really
where this story begins in a serious
kind of way the rest of the 19th century
really plays off the lessons that Sir
George Cayley a staff
delish this thing is one of the most
famous of all designs for airplanes in
the 19th century done by William
Stringfellow and william henson rather
and john stringfellow and of course it's
the aerial steam carriage while the
whole steam carriage for which they
established the joint stock company and
did lots of advertising was never
constructed big enough to carry a human
being several models of it or based on
the idea were constructed this is one of
them you can see that the the model here
is sitting nose down in a chair against
the wall and the tail is the thing of
course pointing for the top of the
screen and in the middle you can see a
little steam engine and the pair of
propellers if you go to the early flight
gallery of the National Air and Space
Museum today you can see a steam engine
very much like the one that powered this
model that was entered in the
Aeronautical Society of Great Britain
competition at the Crystal Palace in
eighteen sixty eight and one the first
award ever given for an aeronautical
propulsion system and it survives in the
collection of the National Air and Space
Museum thanks to Samuel Langley who made
the grand tour of Europe in the 1880s
buying all of the historic flying
machine objects that he could lay his
hands on for his own research and we'll
talk about that in a minute during the
course of the 19th century a lot of
attention is given to people who tried
to build and fly full-scale machines
based really on a minimum of research
they're sort of outside sir george
Kaylee's tradition in that sense and to
make a long story short you can write
most of these people off because their
contribution to the invention of the
airplane while many of them were
interesting people and what they were
trying to do was interesting their
contribution to the final solution of
the problems the flight were
minimal this is an airplane which
probably left the ground for the first
time under power in France in the 1850s
running down a slight incline surface
this is another flying machine from the
last quarter of the 19th century built
by a Russian than Moses key same thing
it went down a ski jump sort of thing
and popped into the air but like do Tom
pool before him and those who followed
in like sir Hiram Maxim whose machine is
shown here there was not enough power to
sustain the machine in the air and no
way to control it in the air and as a
result the contribution was not very
great this slides in backwards but you
can see some of the details of hiram
maxim's machine maximum course was an
American who invented a rapid-fire gun
and couldn't sell it in the United
States went to Europe and made his
fortune in England and was fascinated by
flying machines and built this huge
elephantine machine that you see on the
screen that actually had a crew of three
and it was destroyed when it lifted from
the tracks railroad tracks on which it
was running in Kent in the last decade
of the 19th century again no way to
sustain itself or control itself and
this is the most famous I guess of all
those machines this is Clement Adair's
ill French 1890 which did a lot to
inspire European attempts to invent the
airplane in the decade or so following
this but which again contributed very
little actually in terms of technology
to the invention of the airplane the
real path to the invention of the
airplane there were several approaches
to it one approach came from the fellows
who just built those full-scale machines
and tried them out and as I said that
didn't go very far another approach was
the model approach you know trying to
fly flying machines is obviously a
pretty dangerous enterprise so there
were people who reasoned that if you
could start out with little models and
fly those and learn from that that would
be the safest and most profitable
approach the third approach was the one
that jean-marie LaBrie whom you see on
the screen in the albatross took and
that was to fly gliders to actually
practice flying with unpowered flying
machines during the last quarter of the
19th century people really began to move
beyond Sir George Cayley in a serious
way for the first time and one of the
most important things that happened as I
mentioned the second ago was the
invention of the wind tunnel the wind
tunnel enabled you to put all of those
earlier devices like the whirling arm
and the ballistic pendulum and other
engineering instruments that people had
used to gather data on flight behind you
you could use a wind tunnel properly
configured to really get hard numbers on
the forces acting on model wings that
you established inside the inside the
wind tunnel the wind tunnel of course
was invented in the 1870s by a pair of
Englishmen Frances Herbert wenham was
the most important of the two John
Browning was the other sort of the
mechanic of the pair their original wind
tunnel was almost useless except for
demonstrating the very idea of test
surfaces in which the the wind blew over
the test surface and a and a channel
because they're balanced the thing that
enables you to gather data on the forces
acting on those little test surface
we're so primitive about a decade later
Philips came along and these are
drawings that the Englishman Horatio
Phillips made of air foils that he
tested in his steam injection when
tunnel and it was a real step beyond the
original wind tunnel and pointed really
in the right direction people recognize
pretty quickly the value of this wind
tunnel so by the time you come to the
Wright brothers for example there are
really over a dozen relatively large and
really quite useful wind tunnels
operating here and there around the
world there's one operating here in
Washington for example at Catholic
University when the rights are fiddling
around with their little wind tunnel
that we'll see in a second so the wind
tunnel is an engineering instrument is a
real step forward this is an ornithopter
device powered by rubber as you can see
developed by in english by a frenchman
named Alphonse Pino pineau was another
one of these characters who took a step
beyond Sir George Cayley in his case the
most important thing that he did was to
think seriously about the control issues
how do you control these things once you
get one into the air how are you going
to control it that's something that the
people who came before pineau had spent
all too little time considering he was
really the guy who started people
thinking about control issues he was
also a modeler and one of the things
that he did was to develop really for
the first time although Sir George
Cayley had started down the same path
panou really was the first guy to
develop a model airplane that had some
major of inherent stability in the air
so that you could give it a toss and it
wouldn't fall pitch down or fall off on
one wing or another would fly fairly
steadily forward and he did that by
positioning the the cruciform tails that
he built in in the appropriate the
appropriate way and that was real
important in later years when the wright
brothers looked back and considered who
had really contributed to their own the
understanding that they had begun with
pinole was all
on their list because their focus was on
control as well just as his focus had
had been on control panel might have
really gone places he unfortunately he
was the son of a french admiral who was
severely disabled so that his own label
career was impossible people in France
in the last quarter of the 19th century
didn't take him very seriously so he
took his own life ultimately but he left
a body of work that again would show up
in what Wilbur and Orville Wright did
and be quite important to them I think
almost everybody in the room knows who
this fellow is he's after Sir George
Cayley the next monumental figure in the
history of flight and he comes just as
Cayley had come at the very beginning of
the century Otto Lilienthal comes at the
very end of the 19th century the last
decade lilienthal was a really
fascinating guy he was a big burly
fellow women really loved Otto
Lilienthal there are all kinds of
stories about his his pursuit of the
ladies and so on he was an extraordinary
man at heroic character in the best of
terms people before Otto Lilienthal
Lilienthal wasn't the first guy to glide
I showed you a second ago a picture of
Jean Marie LaBrie's albatross LaBrie
actually broke his leg trying to fly the
albatross and after LaBrie there had
been a couple of other Europeans Louis
Sharum we are a Frenchman who conducted
gliding experiments in North Africa John
Joseph Montgomery an American who
conducted gliding experiments south of
San Diego but when you look at those
gliding experimenters who came before
Otto Lilienthal what you see are guys
who will make one or two tries at this
and become sort of frightening go back
to the drawing board
and that's that's the end of their
they're gliding experience lilienthal
kept going he was trained as a
mechanical engineer and that classic
German tradition that melded theoretical
training and practical experience in
industry and again he was a mechanical
engineer running his own sort of light
machine shop in Berlin he had been
interested in flight since kinas brother
Gustav admin boys and after service in
the franco-prussian war and sort of
getting his business in Berlin on its
feet Lilienthal decided that he could
afford to spend some time and energy
considering the whole question of flight
and he began just to Sir George Cayley
had with laboratory experiments with
engineering experiments and in fact
Lilienthal worked in that regard was
really important in theoretical terms
engineering terms you begin with kaylee
you come through characters like panou
and phillips in the last quarter of the
century who are conducting experiments
with wind tunnels and so on and you end
up with otto lilienthal lilienthal in
1890 publishes the results of Hughes
laboratory research in a book which in
english was called bird flight as the
basis of aviation and like Sir George
Cayley he used his own research work as
a jumping-off point for the design of
aircraft and what you see on the screen
is Lilienthal classic standard flu Goppa
rod his standard monoplane glider and we
think he was probably killed in a
machine like this one he died in a
glider crash in August 1896 he over the
five or six years between eighteen
ninety and 1896 he built in flew 18
distinct glider types and again unlike
everyone who came before him he just did
it time after time after time he
recognized that the only way you could
really gain
it's in the air was by actually getting
out there and doing it and in the
process discovering what changes ought
to be made to your craft when you look
at this picture you can see one of the
great problems that lilienthal faced
clearly Lilienthal is able to build
wings that will lift the weight of his
glider and his own body into the air one
of the really important contributions
that he makes in fact are to be found in
photographs like this when people around
the world saw pictures of this guy in
the air like this you know you could not
you could no longer doubt that the Age
of flight was about the dawn so that was
real important but when you look at this
picture you can see his great problem to
you can see what's happened he's been
flying along coming toward us and a gust
of wind perhaps his has struck his right
wing tip and lifted it and the only way
he has to control his glider to bring
that wing tip down is to swing his own
weight to that side of the airplane
trying to change the center of gravity
of the whole machine in order to bring
that wing tip down well you know that's
okay as long as you're flying something
fairly small but before you know it
you're flying a machine where the change
and the center of gravity that you can
make simply by shifting your torso is
not going to be enough to actually
control the airplane and ultimately
that's what happens to Otto Lilienthal
in August 1896 he's flying at a group of
hills not too far from Berlin he took
the train to get there and stalled his
machine about 50 feet in the air fell
off on one wing and broke his back and
he died in a Berlin hospital the day
after his accident this is lilienthal
with one of his proposed powered gliders
you can see that the forward structure
of the wing looks a little strange
that's because it's part of his proposed
propulsion system and the here he is
landing
and that's a biplane machine of course
as is this one and that one there's I
was going the wrong way there's some
real possibility that in fact he was
killed in a biplane machine this fellow
octave Chanute who was born in Paris in
1832 and who came with his father to the
United States when he was 6 years old
and who wound up as one of the
best-known and most successful civil
engineers in the United States learned
about Lillian balls death just really a
week after it happened he received a
letter from a German friend named
Wilhelm kress who was himself a flying
machine experimenter and who knew
lilienthal well and who knew Octavio
Newt this gentleman well and who wrote
chanute a letter telling him what had
happened to two poor lilienthal chanute
is really sort of the central character
in the book in a dream of wings and
that's the case because he really
creates the social situation that makes
the invention of the airplane possible
as I said he comes to this country at
the age of six he's fascinated by
locomotives he goes to work for the
Hudson River Railroad at the age of 17
in those days if you wanted to become an
engineer you could attend a handful of
American Universities you go to West
Point or Rensselaer Polytechnic was
already teaching engineering courses and
sibley at Cornell as well but you could
also apprentice yourself to a railroad
crew and become an engineer that way and
that's what octane who did and within 10
years of doing that again he had become
the most significant engineers in the
West in addition to being chief engineer
of a bunch of railroads pushing across
the Mississippi into the Kansas cow
towns what are going to become the
Kansas cow towns shouldn't those other
kinds of things that are important to
the history of the West in terms of
engineering he builds the first bridge
across the Missouri River for example at
st. Charles Missouri he designed the
original Union stockyards in Chicago the
stockyards that were destroyed in the
great fire and the original Union
stockyards in Kansas City as well and
he's involved in city planning of a
number of major American cities
including New York chanute was involved
in developing the original plan for the
elevated trains for the city of New York
and so he's he's really a well-known
engineer by the 1870s and he's very
committed to the whole notion of
Professional Engineering too he becomes
the president of the American Society of
Civil Engineers at one point he becomes
the president of the Western society of
Engineers in Chicago where he was based
and the Western society is one of the
great local engineering societies in the
country he becomes the vice president
for engineering of the American
Association for the Advancement of
science and so he's really a sort of a
major public figure who not only can
point to real engineering contributions
but who's important to the
professionalization of engineering as
well a really fascinating guy in the
middle 1870s Chanute went through a
difficult patch in his own life and sort
of had a mini nervous breakdown he took
us whole family back to France and was
giving a great deal of thought to just
sort of how to relax and step away from
the pressures of business a little bit
and to make a long story short he
decided that he was going to really take
a series
interest in flying machines he had
always been fascinated by the the notion
of flight as an engineering problem and
he decided he was going to pursue that
hobby a little bit she knew it was an
extraordinarily methodical man and a
workaholic and he began by getting the
addresses and writing to every single
flying machine pioneer he knew of he
literally began a long correspondence
with people going all the way back to
Frances when it was time to the the
1860s and 1870s and just got to know via
correspondence lots of people who had
contributed to you know flying machine
studies and he also began to discover
talented younger engineers who were
interested in the business of flying
machines too and who perhaps couldn't
afford to pursue their own ideas and
shouldn't begin to offer sums of money
to young engineers and engineers who
were not so young like Louie me art in
in cairo and lawrence hargrave in
australia he really began supporting
these people and introducing promising
young aeronautical talent to the rest of
the world to by hosting sessions of
papers on flying machines at various
engineering society meetings he
organized the great aeronautical meeting
at the chicago world's fair in 1894 and
in fact introduced the American John J
Montgomery to the world at that meeting
no one had ever heard of John Montgomery
before that point so chanute is pretty
rapidly emerging as the centerpiece of
this circle of aviation enthusiasts
people with whom he's writing his
exchanging information writing little
articles and in 1894 he publishes a book
called progress in flying machines
that's based on a series of articles
that he's done again he's planning
aeronautical sessions for engineering
societies so he's becoming
the most visible figures in the history
of aviation one of the people he draws
into the flying machine business is
Samuel Pierpont Langley whom you see on
the screen Langley like Chanute was
pretty much self trained he had
graduated from the Boston Latin School
he was a native of Roxbury Massachusetts
and unlike so many of his schoolmates at
Boston Latin he decided not to go to
Harvard he liked chanute apprenticed
himself as a draftsman than an architect
worked for about ten years in the middle
west at those trades and finally decided
that he just didn't want to do that
anymore his father was fairly wealthy he
was a produce merchant so during the
American Civil War when Sam Langley's
brother John was wounded fighting with
the Union Navy and was recovering Sam
came home and he and John did a tour of
European observatories Langley had
always been fascinated by astronomy and
when they came back from that tour of
European observatories he talked Joseph
winlock who was an old family friend
running the harvard observatory into
taking him on as sort of an apprentice
in astronomy if you can believe that and
that was the start of Langley scientific
career within 20 years of that time
Langley was quite a famous not just
astronomer but manager of science too he
had figured out how to make money
running observatories which is something
that would interest a lot of you folks I
think probably raising money for your
various projects and so on in Langley's
case he did it by figuring out how to
tell satiereal time from the stars
absolutely accurate time and
establishing a system for selling it to
the railroads so that railroads could
keep absolutely accurate time and trains
wouldn't run into one another and all of
that kind of thing so by the mid-1880s
Langley election it has become quite a
famous guy
and he attends a meeting of the american
association for the advancement of
science at which chanute has arranged a
series of aviation papers and it just
strikes a spark with Langley and Langley
comes away from that meeting determined
that he too who's been interested in
flying machines since his boyhood is
going to go out and take a run at this
problem Langley starts with a series of
models he's become by the way the third
Secretary of the Smithsonian Institution
in the mid 1880s he's moved from the
observatory that he's been running in
Pittsburgh to Washington to to manage
the Smithsonian and in the mid-80s he
takes off after the flying machine
problem unlike some of the others he
begins purely as a modeler and you can
see an example of one of his flying
models on the screen rubber powered like
Panoz but you can see some of the other
characteristics the two propellers
pusher propellers he moves ultimately
over a period of a decade from those
little rubber powered flying models that
he flew in the Great Hall of the
Smithsonian to things like this this is
his Langley's airdrome number five which
had a wingspan of about 15 feet and is
powered by the steam engine that you see
there in the center you can see this on
exhibit in the early flight gallery of
the National Air and Space Museum today
and to make a long story short in May of
1896 Langley flew number five for the
first time and that fall he flew another
aerodrome as he called it is number six
with again the wingspan of about 15 feet
a big heavy machine powered by a steam
engine too small to carry a pilot
obviously but certainly large enough to
be real impressive and so in 1896
Langley emerges like lilienthal remember
this is the time when Lilienthal has has
severed his accident and died and
Langley is emerging that spring summer
and fall
as a brand new flying machine hero and
so in fact is his old friends octave
alexander's chanute I'm going to flip
through some pictures chanute in 1896
having done all of this publishing and
written all of those letters given all
of those speeches besides that he too is
going to try his hand at active flying
and he takes a group of these young
engineers whom he's known for some time
to the dunes bringing the southern shore
of Lake Michigan the Indiana Dunes and
he takes a bunch of flying machines out
there and over really the entire summer
of 1896 conducts his own flying machine
trials just like Otto Lilienthal only
this time nobody gets killed the guy
that you see in this machine is Augustus
more herring who's one of chanute
discoveries and herring began his career
building copies of Lilienthal gliders
and of course that's what you see here
and this is one of herrings gliders his
lilienthal in flight I won't apologize
for the quality of some of these
pictures they were taken in 1896 after
all on the dunes and if they look a
little washed out there still still
extraordinary pictures I think this is
Chanute himself and the machine that he
sort of trying on for size was his
multiplying machine a machine that
William Avery built for him here you can
see a later version of it being Teslin
as a kite here if you look real closely
in the center you can see the
multi-plane actually in the air all
those wings could be repositioned to the
front or the rear and you could test
various configurations the final
configuration of the machine which you
see on the screen here had all of those
wings in the big tail surface and they
thought it looked like an insect so they
nicknamed it the katydid
and that's the name that it's that it
retained the katydid and the lilienthal
were both disappointing and they had
gone on to the dunes in the spring of
eighteen ninety six and bye-bye july 4th
they were all ready to go home to
Chicago and see their families and all
that and they were going to come back to
the dunes a little later on in the month
and in fact it's while he's back in
Chicago that chanute learns of Lillian
bells death but it's also while they're
back in Chicago that chanute and herring
begin to think about a new kind of
glider and that's what you see on the
screen they called it the to surface
machine because in its final version it
was a biplane when it was originally
built it was actually a triplane but
there was too much lift in the front of
the machine and so at William Avery's
suggestion that's Avery off on your
right they simply removed the bottom
wing and went with the two top wings and
what you had was the single most
important glider between Otto Lilienthal
and the Wright brothers it was this
glider in fact that served as the Wright
brothers starting point when it came to
structural design of their airplane and
these are just pictures of the 1896 to
surface machine in the air they left the
dunes this is a machine called that was
built by a fella named William Buddhist
law that was tested on the dunes that
that summer as well and was a disastrous
failure so the real important machine
that they came away with was the little
to surface machine herring actually
continued flying another version of the
two surface machine on the dunes on his
own in 1897 and the next year actually
with a tiny little compressed air engine
ran along the sand that st. Joseph
Michigan and actually hopped into the
air with one but of course he couldn't
really really control it
but what was important was the fact that
Chanute the Wright brothers these two
fellows wrote two octave chanute in 1899
89 1918 99 and they sort of announced
themselves as being interested in the
whole flying machine problem I won't
have to tell you too much about these
guys I hope they were of course at the
time operating a bicycle shop on the
west side of dayton ohio on the west
main street of dayton they had been
mechanically inclined all of their lives
and had demonstrated on more than one
occasion as printers and his bike
mechanics and so on their extraordinary
ability to make technological
breakthroughs it's just that until they
came to the airplane the real quality
and the depth of their talent as
intuitive brilliant self trained
engineers didn't really become apparent
until until then they were completely
tied into this chanute Langley
Lilienthal community that I've been
talking about it was Lillian Thals death
in 1896 that sparked their childhood
interest relit their childhood interest
and that simmered over a period of three
years and finally for some very strange
reasons really in the spring of 1899
that spark of interest just burst into
flame and they wrote to the Smithsonian
asking for advice and published
materials and over the few weeks after
receiving those materials from the
Smithsonian Wilbur Wright has this flash
of insight he's going to focus on the
control issues and he builds this
machine probably in late July early
August of 1899 and it of course is the
famous wing warping kite of 1899
and it's the first of the classic series
of right flying machines and this is the
machine which convinces them that again
by manipulating the geography of the
wings they can mechanically control an
airplane in the air what they're worried
about of course is the fact that
lilienthal has been killed because he
couldn't really fully control himself in
the air and so they're absolutely
convinced that they're not going to fly
until they have a real solid grasp of
control and in fact their goal is not so
much to invent the airplane as it is to
invent a aeronautical control system and
once they have that they say to
themselves they'll see what happens just
about halfway down that little ribbon of
sand in the upper right-hand corner of
the picture that's the Outer Banks is
Kitty Hawk North Carolina and that of
course is where the rights went to test
their machines since Dayton is not a
terribly windy place Kitty Hawk which
they thought was going to offer them
strong steady winds pretty much all the
time was where they decided to go to
test their kites when they got down
there they discovered that it wasn't
quite as good as advertised but it was
still a whole lot better than Dayton and
so they stepped from one glider kite
like this one there 1900 machine to the
next part of the the brilliance of the
right solution and we're getting real
close to the end here so I'll close this
off is their ability to there they're
sort of intuitive grasp of the process
of innovation and technology these guys
are not only inventing an airplane
they're sort of inventing the an
engineering process at the same time
that involves how you learn from your
mistakes and apply those lessons to the
design of your next machine in a lot of
ways if you look at these guys between
1899
when they begin in 1903 when they fly
the powered machine for the first time
you might as well think about them at
the beginning is the wrong brothers
because in fact almost everything that
they think they know for sure at the
beginning they discover over the course
of that five year period to have been
incorrect to have been wrong and it's
that learning process that again
intuitive grasp of innovation and the
engineering process that sets them apart
from everybody else I'm just going to
whip through these this will give you
some notion of how much bigger their
1901 glider their second glider was then
the little 1900 glider which had been so
small there was really only one day when
they could actually fly a person on
board they spent almost all of their
time with it flying it as a kite like
this gathering data on the amount of
lift and drag that it was generating and
that's another thing that sort of marks
the genius of of wilbur and orville
wright their ability to okay this thing
is developing far less lift than we
thought and that's disappointing but to
go ahead and figure out how to make use
of this thing anyway together hard data
that they can use to design their next
machine which as you can see was much
larger it was disappointing as well
large enough for them to fly really for
the first time but still disappointing
so over the fall and winter of 1901 back
and Dayton they built their own wind
tunnel and gathered their own data on
the lift and drag of various airfoils
this is their drag balance that you see
and all of that data went into the
design of this machine their 1902 glider
which in many ways was the world's first
airplane they never did patent a powered
flying machine they patented a glider
with their control system onboard a
glider that demonstrated how their
control system work they really figure
that in fact they had invented tooth one
thing and that was a control system that
worked in addition to which they had
gathered a whole bunch of data on the
behavior of and the performance of air
foils and and so on and so forth so the
control system was really what they what
they patented it's going to flip through
some of these to get to this and of
course you come to the 1903 airplane the
world's first airplane which is on
exhibit in our Museum at the National
Air and Space Museum and which is the
end product of everything that we've
been talking about the Wright brothers
again are brilliant intuitive engineers
there are all kinds of reasons why they
achieved solutions to problems that had
baffled everyone who would come before
them personal qualities and all of those
sorts of things talents that set them
apart from everyone else but at the same
time they grew out of this community of
interest in things aeronautical that had
begun in this country really with
octavio Newt and his vast circle of
Correspondence in the last decade of the
19th century and in very real terms what
you see on the screen the 1903 airplane
was the most important outcome of that
circle of wings that that had included
people who first took the last serious
steps toward the solution of the
problems of flight so my times up and
I'll call it quits if we could bring the
likes up if anybody has any questions
I'll do my best to try to answer them
for you Whitehead this array
good stuff the gentleman's asking about
Gustave Whitehead who was a native of
Germany who'd come to this country in
the late 19th century through Brazil he
was a seaman and who sort of popped up
in Boston in the late 19th century and
worked for a group of Boston
aeronautical enthusiasts and in the
summer of nineteen oh one claimed to
have made some significant flights near
bridgeport connecticut including one
flight of seven miles over Long Island
Sound you know going to talk like this
you can't talk about everybody but
Whitehead is in fact intimately involved
with this community of flying machine
experimenters that and talking about to
the Boston friends of octave chanute
zoom chanute had inspired and who
founded their own aeronautical society
were the guys who hired Whitehead
originally to build gliders for them and
people like Langley we're always
watching what Whitehead was doing but I
think your question really relates to
the amount of credence that I give to
the the claims for long flights by
Gustave Whitehead in the summer of 18 of
19 01 and I don't think that the
evidence supports those those claims
there are a lot of people who would
disagree with me but that's my opinion
ha holler folks by the way whenever I
have to whenever we have to really call
it quits here yo do you have any
evidence to indicate that Sir George
Cayley or Langley or
or any of those had any access or
knowledge of work Daniel Bernoulli sure
Daniel Bernoulli was one of the earlier
figures really in the Scientific
Revolution one of the physicists and
Bernoulli of course was the guy who
established what we now know as as
Bernoulli's principle there there again
the work of physicists from Galileo
through people like Bernoulli to people
like Sir Isaac Newton that work was
known by all of these characters part of
the problem was I talked about sort of
the difference between science and
engineering at the outset part of the
problem was it was difficult to apply
those sort of basic physical principles
to what was going on here so what these
fellows discovered was that the
engineering process in other words where
you build a wing you test it you capture
the data about the forces operating on
that surface and you use that to design
the next machine that was the best way
to approach the design of an airplane
that actually worked one of the
interesting things about the airplane in
very broad terms the Wright brothers of
course understood that the difference in
pressure on the wing of an airplane and
that sort of thing but they couldn't
explain to you in any detailed way why
their airplane really flew it was the
fact that airplanes were in the air that
sort of inspired the birth of
theoretical aerodynamics in the German
universities in the decade after the
invention of the airplane so that by the
middle of the 1920s wing theory is in
place and somebody can actually go to a
blackboard and described in general
terms what's happening around that wing
but that's that's really something
that's inspired by the fact that these
machines are already in the air and you
can go out and see them work
the steam engine is sort of that way to
the steam engine is one of those devices
like the airplane that grows out of
engineering work really and inspires
science it's the the desire to make
steam engines more efficient than
powerful and so on and so forth that
sort of inspires the birth of
thermodynamics just as the existence of
the airplane sort of inspires the desire
to really understand what's happening at
a theoretical level one more question
and then we'll have to have to call it
quits now okay thanks very much for your
patience
Tom thank you very much delightful Tom
Crouch was named by President Clinton to
chair the first flight Centennial
advisory board to plan for the
Centennial flight of 2003 a dream of
wings Americans and the airplane is
published by Norton visit w w9 com